Сара, Айя та Шахіда - три однокласниці,
три мусульманки. Шахіда носить хіджаб, відколи їй виповнилося 10.
Утім, деякі німецькі політики хочуть заборонити носіння хіджаба для дівчат до 14 років.
Шахіду це обурює.
- Мені лише 12, і якщо мені скажуть: ти мусиш зняти хустину,
я відповім: ні, це моє рішення, ви не можете мені вказувати,
ви не мої батьки, ви не мої опікуни, ви мені ніхто.
- Я теж хочу носити хіджаб, але коли стану старшою,
коли дозрію до того, щоб ухвалювати власні рішення.
Власне, щодо того, коли саме дівчинка достатньо зріла,
щоб самостійно ухвалювати рішення про носіння хіджаба,
точаться дискусії в Німеччині.
Міністр з інтеграції землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія переконаний, що до 14 років - ні.
- Для нас украй важливо, щоб тут ішлося саме про самоствердження.
Ми поважаємо рішення жінок, які добровільно вирішують носити хіджаб,
тож тут не йдеться про дискримінацію.
Але ми хочемо, щоб молодих дівчат не змушували до цього.
Більшість школярок у цій школі кажуть, що носять хіджаб добровільно.
Або ж планують робити це в майбутньому.
Це непокоїть учителів.
Разом із тим вони вважають заборону контрпродуктивною.
- Для мене як для вчительки дуже важливо дискутувати з дівчатами на цю тему,
але не через заборони, а шляхом діалогу зі школярками,
які зараз перебувають у пошуку себе і, ймовірно,
розцінюють хіджаб як ознаку самоідентифікації.
Слід з'ясувати, чи це їхнє особисте рішення.
Це можливо лише, коли є довіра у стосунках.
Це непросто: більшість дітей просто перейняли в питанні хіджаба
ставлення батьків.
- Я вважаю, що з підліткового віку слід носити хіджаб,
тобто з 14-15 років, щоб до дівчини не чіплялися.
- Мої сестри також почали носити хіджаб.
Я побачила, що я єдина, хто його не носить,
і сказала: окей, я теж вдягну хіджаб.
- Це релігійні традиції, яких, звісно,
продовжують дотримуватися в сім'ях.
І також у мечетях це теж так розцінюється.
Школа, вважають вчителі ісламу,
саме те місце і той вік, коли слід говорити з дівчатами на цю тему.